[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to a special marvel's avengers
war table deep dive
a new format that focuses on one topic
and today that's our first new hero of
season one
kate bishop since launch in september
millions of you have started on this
journey with us
kamala surprised many of you with her
disarming sincerity
going from fangirl to avenger
the initial story of kamala reassembling
the avengers is the foundation for all
our content to come
which continues our world story with new
heroes and story experiences
at no additional cost season 1 kicks off
with kate bishop
operation taking aim which will be
available december 8th
kate's operation is the first new
chapter in season 1 of the avengers
initiative
after coming back together and standing
up to aim the first battle was won
but the war is far from over the new
leader of aim has far-reaching plans and
that story continues
with kate bishop in operation taking aim
better come back all right i'll try but
if i don't nope
not having that conversation you know we
thought you were dead
nobody heard from you it's a bridge
through time
nobody's been foolish enough to actually
try it i'm not giving up on my friend
katie we're talking about time
collapsing in on itself
eventually tear reality apart ooh okay
uh i have so many questions um but i
like the energy
so let's just turn this thing on before
i ever think did
did you not just hear me say tearing
reality apart
we're gonna go get clint out of the
wrong timeline cut monica off from her
future self
simple i like it that's still messing
with time that's that
that might work
we have one shot at this
[Music]
great let's go get hawkeye
you don't understand i agreed to this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
operations are new story experiences
that can feature new playable heroes
villains biomes and more we planned from
the beginning to build an
interconnected narrative that unfolds
and evolves as we release new content
operations feature beats of new story
that work together to form an arc
like a run of comics or episodes in
season of a show
kate's operation comes with her own
story and unique rewards that you can
only get in taking aim in taking
aim kate is searching for her mentor
hawkeye but along the way she discovers
a conspiracy involving commander nick
fury
time travel and a frightening new enemy
the super adaptoid
super adaptoid was originally introduced
in tales of suspense number 84.
it has a cosmic origin and is programmed
to defeat captain america by copying the
abilities of the avengers
in marvel's avengers it has all of the
avengers powers and is considered an
omega level threat in the tougher
multiplayer only version of the super
adaptoid boss fight
arcade bishop is voiced by ashley burch
best known for her roles as tiny tina in
borderlands 2 and
a loy in horizon zero dawn and chloe
price in life is strange
we are so excited to welcome ashley to
the cast oh hi
what's up what took you so long fighting
robots
me too oh
kate learned much of what she knows from
clint so that's reflected in her kit
but she has her own heroics and
finishers and intrinsics
kate bishop is a world-class archer and
an adept swordswoman
with repurposed aim tech she uses
quantum energy to power a unique set of
special abilities
her intrinsic attacks teleport to the
enemy and deal increased sword damage
while her blank skills let her double
jump air dash and traverse ledges via
short range teleportation
[Music]
kate can parry enemies with quantum
shift teleporting away from the attack
and striking from behind
as a master archer kate has a wide
variety of bow skills each with upgrades
that can be unlocked
for starters her razor arrows can be
fired in a rapid
three-shot ranged combo or can be fired
with perfect timing for bonus damage
you can fire multiple arrows at the same
time with scatter shot arrows
which is handy for crowd control or for
doling out damage to enemies close up
explosive arrows are great for
staggering enemies and breaking through
their defenses
and don't forget smoke screen arrows do
high stun damage to anything inside the
cloud of smoke
[Music]
kate's heroics are unique to her and fit
her personality to a tee
decoy is kate's support heroic and it is
one of our favorites
it spawns a hologram replica of her that
shoots arrows of quantum energy at
targets to distract them
after image lets you swap places with a
decoy and self-destruct remote detonates
the decoy to trigger a large burst of
quantum damage
her warp arrow assault heroic allows her
to teleport over long distances while
triggering a large quantum explosion
that lifts enemies into the air on her
arrival
wormhole is an upgrade option for warp
arrow that creates portals allies can
use to quickly teleport across the
battlefield to join
kate the ultimate heroic quantum
overdrive provides unlimited
intrinsic energy empowering her bow so
she can fire quantum energy arrows with
explosive results kate also has a host
of quick and agile sword strikes to deal
with enemies that foolishly venture
within striking distance
as you can see kate has a plentiful
arsenal at her disposal to
wreck shop on aim and then some
[Music]
every new hero comes with a ton of
cosmetics including emotes costumes
takedowns and nameplates
many of these can be earned through
gameplay but players can also purchase
certain cosmetics for their favorite
heroes
once you complete kate's story you can
jump into a late game version of kate's
final mission to test your skills and
earn even better rewards
before we go here's a quick look at
what's coming after kate
hawkeye operation future imperfect
clint's story picks up after the
conclusion of kate's operation and
brings us face to face with a distant
future where
all hope is lost clint and the operation
hawkeye future imperfect will be
available early 2021
we'll have more details including
in-depth first looks at his gameplay in
the very near future
season one of the avengers initiative
will bring big changes and that
all starts with story that includes next
gen
marvel's avengers is coming to next gen
consoles early 2021
and all current owners will receive a
free upgrade on both platforms
until then your current game can be
played on the new consoles
including cross gen play and you'll
notice improved performance already with
the new hardware
our journey began with kamala's single
player story and will grow with both
kate and clint's operations
and we have more improvements and
features yet to come
we're always listening to our players
including asks for future features like
cross platform play
we hear you loud and clear as always
thank you for always telling us what you
think make sure you visit
playavengers.com for our weekly blog
where you can find everything from patch
notes to tips and fun content that you
created
until then we'll see you online and in
the game
[Music]
you